[Music]
hey gq i'm art williams celebrity barber
today we're gonna give my man julian a
high top fade inspired by will smith
first crunch in bel air
what's up man how you doing
man when's the last time you got a
haircut bro man it's been it's been a
few months i can see how we can
take this
and get you something real fresh man
we're gonna make you look like the fresh
prince we're going to take a look at his
hair evolution throughout the seasons of
fresh prince
so this season one right here he has a
top fade right there look his size are
not ball but more like a shadow fade
season two
we see the evolution of like almost like
a slope kind of goes up a little higher
in the front season three i don't even i
don't know what that is i think he was
on his
crisscross thing back yeah this is more
like it right here this is the will
smith the fresh prince that i remember
i think this look right here would be
perfect for you i like how clean it is
it looks sharp yeah not too not too low
yeah you know i've been wanting to do
something different i think i want to go
with this one right here you're probably
the closest young looking little smith
i've ever seen so we'll make that happen
for you your hair texture is not the
same texture as
will's is in this photo right here but
we can still make it happen here's what
we're gonna do i'm gonna first spray it
down a little bit with water kind of
pick it out see how high his hair really
is i'm gonna grab the sides i'm going to
start cutting the sides build a
guideline so i have a vision of where i
want to go with this fade how high i
want to go how low i want to go and then
we're just going to keep moving through
this haircut as smoothly as possible
clean up his beard make sure we line up
his mustache nice and smooth so let's
get started
you don't want to comb
dry hair because it'll cause a lot of
breakage so i'm just going to wet it
down a little bit and then pick it out
you always want to start
up at the end of the hair and then work
your way down to the root because you
don't want to end up breaking hair
or knotting hair you good
because we have this kind of like a
mushroom shape for his head right now
i'm going to start with
these sides that are spilling over first
you can't see the name on here because i
use it all the time but this is a wall
magic clip i'm going to start with this
clipper and i'm gonna have it keep it
closed all the way so i'm gonna close it
just to kind of get a shape to start to
shape this the top of his head
and i am going to use my flat top cone i
just envisioned myself as a painter and
just
stroking
like paintbrush just stroking the hair
it's kind of going out a little bit but
eventually as we get through this
haircut i'll
do more shaping
[Music]
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to take my flat top comb
and i'm going to start to make his sides
a little bit short these sides that i
have kept long i can make shorter
without actually digging into the
haircut and making it short too fast i'm
going to take my
number one guard and i'm going to start
to just kind of lightly blend the line
out the guideline that i have
grabbed my seven inch comb again i'm
gonna go a little bit smaller with the
fade guard
we haven't cut the top yet we just kind
of cut the sides but we're already at
healthier hair on the sides of your head
right now i'm gonna work my way through
transitioning this into this we'll start
to see the hair come together a little
bit more and we'll start to see the hair
actually stand as a box
now that we got him looking like
looks more like kid from kid and play
we're gonna
begin to just kind of lower this down i
might follow it up with my andes
t-liners
[Applause]
so what lets you become a barber
oh man
short story is i would go my stepdad
would drop me off at the barber shop
every saturday morning and i would just
sweep the floor
all day long and sometimes they tip me
out they give me a tip and sometimes
they just give me a free haircut we
thought the barbers was the richest
people on the planet at that point i
mean
i probably fell in love with the money
first and then
as i got into it
that's when the artistry of it started
to come into fruition i'm gonna pick it
out
and we're gonna see even though it's
kind of starting to get a nice shape to
it when i pick it out it's you're gonna
see like longer hair underneath here
again you want it to be able to keep its
shape for when he has to maintain it
himself
[Music]
i leave it
one area just almost completely undone
as much as it's a reveal for the client
it's a reveal for the barber too so with
18 years of being a barber how many
times you think you've given this cut
one
no i'm joking
being that i live in portland
portland oregon the young people in
portland are getting this haircut all
the time believe it or not
so what i'm going to do now is take my
outliners i'm going to give them a nice
sharp line or cool on later in the fresh
princess in the seasons you can see his
line progressively got a little sharper
and sharper and so we're going to go
with that sharper line
[Music]
this might be the most important part of
the haircut i usually like to keep the
line as natural as possible so when i do
the front line
this front line of a hairline i usually
like to just
start right in the middle just
put a line right in the middle and then
bring the corners to meet that line
usually you get a straight line that way
so now that i can kind of see
what i'm working with more clearly now i
just want to
begin to
find detail
so now i'm just going to shave the
excess hair off his face
got a baby beard going here and yeah i
just hope you know it took me 17 years
to grow that
so
[Music]
i'm going to use a brush this time a
little softer on face than a comb
you got a good mustache though
i think i was 27 before i got a mustache
i feel very lucky
[Music]
what i have here is just a little small
bottle of
astringent for the skin the name of this
formula is called cool player so it
might sting a little bit
yeah that's definitely a sting on there
[Music]
you know you've been to the barber shop
when you get that sting so i'm gonna
spray
some orb
hairspray
on him just a little sheen and holding
spray basically to kind of hold this in
place but it smells good as well so
and just like that we're done you ready
for this and i'm really excited man
i'm excited for you
all right
doing what you got
oh
yeah
yeah this is fresh prince
oh that fade is so cool man you got the
mustache
and you got a spot on
[Music]
thank you man yeah to say that yeah this
thing is spot on the good thing about
this though
is that you don't gotta stay the fresh
prince
you can take your leave-in conditioner
yeah and put it in there and curl your
hair up and you'll be
basically the new
fresh prince improved you know what i
mean yeah yeah
how you feeling jay no i'm feeling good
you're looking good
you like that inner fresh prince you
know let me hear you let me hear that
inner fresh prince come out of you now
this is a story all about my life got
flipped turned upside down and i'd like
to take a minute just sit right there i
tell you i became the prince of a town
called belen
hey